uh if you guys haven't seen the part one
of this you guys can go check it out it
will be in the description below but a
lot of folks got mad at fresh and fit
for the way that they kicked out their
guests asian doll all right guys guys
sidebar sidebar conversations please all
right what have i told you this is like
you know that's like the fifth time i've
told you that right something like stop
for real like stop hey mean
like you haven't been here
yeah it's the whole show yeah she's been
doing the whole show i'm not mean to so
are you gonna come on somebody's show
not know go down and say oh you're mean
have you been here the whole time no all
right then so you don't know what was
happening
you're not gonna come on the platform
i think that the coverage from a lot of
people has been a bit disingenuous and
unfair from my perspective the guess who
comes on the pod right the woman who
kept interrupting multiple times of
doing like little side conversation
stuff like that
was
being disrespectful to
the podcast itself right she was
creating bad because here's the thing if
you're having a podcast and someone's
talking while other people having
conversations the mic still picks it up
so it overlaps okay so it's bad
podcasting to have guests who do that
and they warned her multiple times and
eventually blew up okay my thing is this
all right meyer goes on to say i won't
let come on someone come on the podcast
and disrespect it they're not going to
come on the platform
my thing is this
brother y'all disrespect your own
podcast i i won't stand for people
coming out here disrespecting the
podcast
but you invite the exact same type of
women who come in week in week out to do
the exact same type of behavior and then
constantly you have to boot them out at
some point you also have to acknowledge
that your selection process because
here's the thing you can clown on women
all you want the only type of woman you
invite are ig girls right women who are
there for clout okay so you only invite
one type of woman right who has no care
for your podcast just wants to get the
[ __ ] benefit of some clicks right you
didn't fed her at any type of way okay
you didn't look into her past you didn't
find out what kind of guest she was you
saw her picture and her looks and you
said you should come on the pot
i find it fascinating that there's such
an emphasis on respect
yet the only criteria for the women you
bring on the show is how they look in
their ig pictures only bring them on the
show for their looks
but you're surprised when they don't
have much character y'all are out here
hiring models and then being surprised
when they don't have degrees in rocket
science wake the [ __ ] up so
you
invite strangers
into your home
on a regular basis
people you have no conception of what
they're like
roll dies and say you're not going to
disrespect you're disrespecting your own
space
all right you're you're this is you're
putting when when someone pulls out a
gun
supposedly apparently allegedly who
knows what happened you're disrespecting
your own space as well you're not taking
the security of everyone else gets
involved because you're inviting random
people that you haven't vetted
having
crazy conversations talking to them in a
wild manner
how is that respectful to the folks
around you you get what i'm saying
but it's also to prove a point that you
know women are like that and this and
that and that and whatever here's a
problem you say women are like that
right you make those kind of claims one
you're a miami bunch of weirdos two you
only invite women who are on ig
trying to get clout so your selection
bias is there so here you are making
sweeping statements like these are the
modern women you see how the modern
women works this is what women are like
but that's how you do that look at the
women you're choosing to come on the pot
it's always the same right yeah and also
you know some people do this right
they'll slander them they'll be like oh
look at this in-cell energy right and
i'm not a big fan of doing that okay
because generally when i think you use
like terms like that i feel like there's
just a way to label like a terrible oh
yeah you're a terrorist or you're uh
okay they always do stuff like that
right yeah
but what you can't deny is
they love having opportunities to kick
women off and dudes love it i remember i
was getting comments from a bunch of
their fans and being like you just mad
because you don't have a podcast like
them you mad that you're not out here
kicking out ratchet women every day i'm
like is that something to be proud of
that you're constantly like your highest
viewed videos is you uh frank castling
bimbos you know what i'm saying like i
just and just because your your reality
is ours doesn't mean that we're wrong
like we live this lifestyle this is who
we are yeah bro so hey man you know what
it is bro someone mad that they can't do
what we do that's that's what it really
is man yeah facts you know what i'm
saying
and i don't even want it to our own horn
but think about it bro monday we talk to
you guys about making money right we
brought
grant cardone robert kiyosaki you know
i'm saying critically acclaimed authors
guys that are multi-millionaires
billionaires on the show teach you how
to make money wednesdays we talk about
dating right you know what kills me
about these guys they always talk about
yeah we're making men's lives so much
better our channel's about doing all
this stuff if you go look at the views
on their videos
none of them are on the videos where
they're supposedly helping men none of
the men are tuning in for financial
advice the men are not tuning in for
fitness advice they're not tuning for
another you know what they tune in for
women getting dunked on bimbos getting
kicked out so i think this whole like
disingenuous thing where you're like
we're helping me get better i mean i'm
sure there's a small section of men who
are appreciated your brain is built on
dunking on women there's a certain level
of like you bring this energy and you
encourage it and then after that you
want to make sweeping generalizations
about women but it's like brev you're
not even trying to choose ladies who can
offer a different perspective yeah but
we're but we're jealous
yeah true i'm super taller listen
myron's angry and i understand why
he suffers from extremely smooth skin
on the top of his cranium okay
when you're balding
that's tough it's even tougher when
people notice because the skin's so
smooth and i want you to have skin as
smooth as myron's bald spot with today's
sponsor tj henley that bald spot is so
smooth it would make nappa proud
dragon ball z reference y'all gonna love
that meg shout out to our sponsors they
don't give a [ __ ] what i say
i get compliments on my skin all the
time people be asking what's your skin
care routine how do you get your skin
and for a lot of fellas talking about
skin care is a little bit awkward
because either we're too ashamed to do
it or it seems a little bit too feminine
but the truth is having rough skin or
having all these little dents everywhere
isn't something that you necessarily
want especially if it's things that you
can easily avoid through very very good
products i recommend going through that
process and that's where tiege hanley
comes in they got a great system in
place where you can use their products
to achieve your skin care goals i
personally recommend that you start with
the level one system which comes with
all the basics a daily face wash which
gets rid of all the dirt and grime on
your face then got a two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of all the
dead skin cells and an am moisturizer
with spf 20 because we all need to make
sure that our skin is protected from the
sun and the cool thing about the
channels all their boxes come with
instructions in addition to amazing skin
members of th handling get tons of
benefits like at least 20 percent off
retail price the ability to pause or
cancel at any time as well as free us
shipping and because ta shanley is
sponsoring today's video if you go to
the link in the description below not
only will you get all the benefits that
i just listed but you'll also get a free
gift with your purchase rub out that
face so you can actually start looking
fresh
we're jealous
there's so much we don't have we don't
have what they have right yeah you're
just mad because you don't throw people
out i don't need to i did that enough of
my life
as a pouncer that i don't i don't want
to do it online on top of that yo
and you saw them right ladies pulling
out guns folks pulling out what weapons
all this stuff right eventually it's
going to go too far when you watch them
just watch the energy modern comes out
women with versus men he'll let dudes
interrupting on a regular basis cut him
off anything ladies and gentlemen this
man loses his cool i remember even when
i went on the podcast how quickly he
kicked out the girl i was like what
happened
hey can you stop cutting me off
is there a problem stop cutting me off
do you want me to leave yeah leave i was
like whoa you said my face
how did this escalate so fast you truly
love them you take them back because you
know who you fell in love with you know
who that person is
and everybody has downs everybody goes
through the parish and everybody has bad
moments you know yeah
all right let me translate that woman
ease for you guys uh basically what
she's saying is as long as you continue
to be who you were when i first met you
then i will i don't think she said that
i did not say that that is men's
planning and you're changing my word but
that's not how the world works i think
that's what you've learned in life
seriously can you stop cutting me off
are you do you feel like i'm cutting you
off i think this was like a conversation
not a monologue no no
did you not ask a question
i'm sorry did you not ask me a question
yeah i was asking you what is
unconditional love and then you cut me
off twice i counted it are you mad hey
listen not at all
said this over and over again
yes it's me i'm the producer okay
do not cut martin off it's bad radio
now you get one final warning if not we
have three ladies on the couch
i don't mind
this show
i was able to have calm conversations
with everybody this dude couldn't hold
himself together but again
i don't got an issue with it i just find
it funny that all these like alpha male
high value man whatever it is right okay
have zero ability
to compose themselves right they want to
lead men but they but they can't manage
their own emotions well you know what
i've
i think what people are starting to
realize
is that all these guys who are like the
alpha and all that stuff a lot of them
are just frauds
period well you know there's a lot of
projection there's a lot of ideas of
what you want to be and someone said
something's funny he's like man listen i
follow what they say not what they do
which i get because somebody could come
in and preach a good game
right your pastor might be
singing the bible
what he's behaving as is completely
different right
so maybe there is some truth in the
things that they're saying okay
but i always have a hard time taking
somebody seriously
who's telling me like hey this is how
you manage your money
but you constantly using yours yeah you
get what i'm saying right well someone
who's super hyper unsuccessful is trying
to coach me on how to be successful it
makes me look at them a little bit
sideways yeah why don't you just shoot
that [ __ ] on you yeah yeah cause i
remember when primerica and and acn yeah
and excel and all those people part
parliament things yeah primary schemes
period pyramid schemes and then that
they used to come up to you and be like
yeah you in a few months you're
you're gonna have a ferrari i'm going to
have if i'm going to come back and see
me when you got that ferrari that wasn't
in 2005 i'm still waiting you know what
i mean like come and see me you're
you're driving into yourself just like i
am so go ahead go over there and succeed
and come back to me and that's where the
uh flashy thing is
can you because
that's where the flashy thing is if you
look successful and what is success to
people driving big expensive car you
even know if they're rentals it doesn't
matter you're driving that [ __ ] the
kind of woman that you you you you're
with so if you surround yourself with
that and you paint that picture as is
that is success that's what success is
so you drive those rented cars you you
you you live oh i'mma live in miami
heart of miami whatever whatnot but
really what is it yeah is that is that
what that's what your success is it's
only that and it's based out of nothing
then
you're gonna see some father you clearly
see some flaws so yeah you drive
expansive cars and stuff like that but
it's not really it you know i mean it's
it's a facade it's a it's a yeah that's
what it is it's marketing the marketing
is not necessarily good but it's good
enough so that there's a lot of people
that don't see through it yeah yeah i
agree with that listen we want to hear
what you guys think what do you guys
think in the comments below let us know
wanna hear from